okay so here's the Dragon Ball Z double
I am 99 sure you have never seen uh the
Christian dump right baptisms on your
blue card and we'll contact you I'm
going to power up now
okay okay it's not really a Christian
dub per se what it is is a piece of lost
media someone has recently uncovered
from a 2004 Evangelical Church from the
sounds of it they created this little
parody dub as a promotion for some
upcoming event they had but honestly I
just cannot get over how funny this
thing is
church not being in Squires next week
it's going to be in the Haymarket
theater do you understand the whole
thing is over five minutes long and it
has just about everything
hey regular cat what's up
hello regular cat how's the altitude
treating you oh what's wrong Dudley
there's only one announcement left ha